all right when you look inside  yourselves huh do you see a knight a  Viking samurai perhaps huh  when your enemies are arriving at the  gates and sword is coming at your head  would you turn and run would you stand  and fight my name is Jason Vandenberg  creative director for honor offers you  the opportunity to experience the  adrenaline and the danger of a melee  combat in a visceral battlefield through  a new type of gameplay that we call the  art of battle you will feel the weight  of the weapon in your hand the crash as  you block the attack and the impact when  you strike the winning blow but bring  your friends with you because while a  single individual can win a fight it  takes a band of warriors to win a battle  and when I say a band of warriors  [Applause]  I'm into teams of four warriors in a  live multiplayer demonstration on  console right now  [Applause]  [Applause]  raaah  [Applause]